我认为普通人做短日频最有用的
也最应该做的一个方法是什么
正好马上就过年了嘛
然后我在我们社群也给大家分享的这么一个方法
就是你给自己刺典一个很小的计划
哪怕是一个很小的计划
比如说半年或者一年
比如说我小伙似乎我做短日频账号
或者我做个小商品
这是一个非常值得去做的事情
比如去做自己事儿去行了
这是你最应该做的事情
但同时会有一个
你应该做我切最好一定做的最好的一个方法是什么呢
就是把你的学习曲线再讲出来
你就只要去做事儿你一定会有问题
你一定一定要卡点
那你就给两分一讲说
哎呦我这是我做短日频账号的第一天
然后呢
我现在遇到的卡点
就是我拍的拍着都没有领那了
对吧
我现在是做商品的第一天
然后做做什么
我发现我的产品买不出去对不对
你有一个卡点
那你有这个卡点的话
你一定要去解决
你就给大家讲
我是用了那些绝方法
第一个方法
第二个方法
第三个方法
然后那个十八的方法
那个成功了
然后我做个对比
最后我才能在个方法把这个问题解决了
最后那个方法
我就去做事儿
这就是复材品
我就跟你分享我的学义曲线
那么这种分享有什么好处呢
首先第一个应有卡点
这就会产生不明
你要知道就是你一段的问题
别人也会遇到
只要你做这个事儿
基本上这个事儿都会遇到
原来你有这样一个问题
对吧
你和我其实是一样的
短人民里边一个很重要的动力就要的公民
就是能和别人
就是情绪公民
第二个事儿就是什么东西
就是当你做一件事的时候
一定要把它的财政成组的刚刚小事儿
因为你太多的支持
你像我有的时候
再去给大家分享一些
细节的时候
我希望分享不了了
因为我已经获了
我不知道你可能会有一个卡点
而且我赚的卡点
我会认为那个事儿还用分享吗
但是恰恰是你是在行李的公中
你就会那些大事儿就会说
财政成组的那个小事儿
而那些小事
恰恰是可以行动的那个利涂
然后这样的东西的话
就可以把职合行去连接在一起
它没有任知负责的过程
那么这张的知识
它是可以用的
它是有用的
澳志的短政成组的第二个特征
就是它这个用的
然后你做各种各样的实验
然后你实验完了以后
你会得到一个结果
然后这个时候你会有突破
这个时候的突破
是人们真正要学的东西
就是你是怎么获得这个灵篮的
你是怎么突破的
哇我通过你的这个视频
我得到一种灵感
我有一种废物
对吧
我有一种新的想法
这是短视频的第三个东西
就是我看一段频
我要不然过敏
我要不然用
要不然我产生了一种新的想法
新的灵感
这是它的作用
那其实还有一个的点是什么呢
就是因为你是在持续的做事
所以你总是遇到卡电
你现在把做事的过程中
地图里边遇到的机会
卡电都给大家分享了
相当一个连转
那这种连转的话
就会让人们一直持续关注你
但是一直就会有影响你
这事做短视频最好的方法
所以我给大家建议是什么呢
整好在过年的这段时间
快过年了
我给大家建议就是
你给自己制定一个计划
不用什么大事
就是个小事
半年或者一年
要不结果说
我要不然做的小生意
要不然干点什么
这个事是值得做的
这是这段的事情
但是同时你把你的学义曲线
然后你对了卡电
然后你的长事
然后你是怎么解决
你是怎么突破的
深阳出来
这是最好的
我认为短视频
就是普通人做短视频的方法